alors triste henri emile chapleau
bonsoir
[Applaudissements]
tristan vous êtes né femme mais vous
êtes toujours senti hommes c'est
pourquoi vers l'âge de 20 ans vous
décidé d'entamer un traitement pour
devenir un homme mais après votre
rencontre avec beef vous décidé
d'arrêter le traitement pour avoir un
enfant ou devenez alors pour les médias
l'homme enceinte ce soir en slt vous
nous raconter votre incroyable histoire
[Musique]
ou une clientèle
tristan vous êtes défi le 24 septembre
1982 à vancouver au canada père médecin
et mère physiothérapeute vous avez deux
soeurs
+2 soeur adoptive parce que vos parents
étaient extrêmement généreux finalement
je dirais même qu'ils avaient plus de
deux enfants supplémentaires
c'est-à-dire qu'il ya toujours eu des
adolescents des enfants dans mon
entourage qui avait besoin d'un
peut-être de médias permettant alors
très tôt vous ne vous sentez pas bien
dans votre corps de fille mais cela ne
vous pose pas de problème pour votre
scolarité
vous avez des amis vous êtes entouré
vous faites du théâtre vous faites de la
musique et même du violoncelle
c'est tout à fait ça mon enfance était
tout à fait normal de parent aimant
beaucoup d'amis mais je savais qu'il y
avait quelque chose de différent quelque
chose qui n'allait pas à l'intérieur de
moi même c'est vers 18 ans que vous
entendez parler pour la première fois du
phénomène transgenres d'hommes né dans
les corps de femme ou l' inverse et vous
réalisez que vous êtes un homme gay dans
un corps de femme j'ai l'impression
d'être fou quand vous vous rendez compte
de ça non ah ya ce cas oui
c'est vraiment quelque chose de très
près dix ans et c'est difficile de
savoir qu'il ya quelque chose à
l'intérieur de soi même on regarde le
miroir et on voit quelque chose de
différent c'est comme une sorte de
trahison chaque jour
et tout le monde vous appelle madame
mademoiselle et et moi je me disais mais
non non je suis un homme
[Musique]
là vous décidé d'entreprendre en
changement de sexe vous voulez devenir
un homme au sens physique du terme alors
pour ne pas brusquer vos parents quand
même vous y aller doucement vous
commencez par vous couper les cheveux
c'était le premier geste de votre
transformation et vous demander à être
appelé tristan vous commencez à vous
injecter de la testostérone
courageux
l'impression de faire sa part courage
pour moi c'était plutôt quelque chose
qui me sauvé la vie
une chose était très clair c'est à dire
que je ne pouvais plus vivre cette vie
en tant que femme puisque je savais que
j'étais un homme et donc soit je faisais
une transition soit et bien j'avais tout
simplement mourir
roselyne sala et c'est un futur macro
le combat pour l'acceptation des
transgenres ça a été à des combats de ma
vie g
fais en sorte que le transgenre ne soit
plus considérée comme une maladie
psychiatrique et que pour autant parce
qu'on quand j'ai voulu faire ça la
sécurité sociale m'a dit ah si c'est
plus de maladies psychiatriques on
prendra plus en charge à 100% les
médicaments et les opérations
nécessaires à la transition et j'ai
voulu que néanmoins ce ne soit plus
considérée comme une maladie
psychiatrique et qu'on puisse financer
les opérations et les traitement médical
qui permettent cela
au
ça prend un enfant bipolaire ouais
à cette époque tristan vous menacez
beaux-parents de couper les ponts avec
eux s'ils continuent à vous appeler l
après plusieurs années après plusieurs
années je leur ai dit qu'ils g t il
résister encore un petit peu et donc
pour moi
je pouvais les laisser s'habituer mais
au bout d'un moment il fallait que je
leur dise bon voilà qui vaut parents ont
quand même été très inquiet mais bientôt
ils ont été rassurés parce qu'ils ont vu
vous aviez des amis que je viens
l'entourage n'était pas solitaire et
finalement entre un enfant transgenres
et un enfant mort ils ont choisi
l'enfant tranchant
tout ce que vous voyez sur les
transgenres à la télévision mais a cédé
problème on crée des problèmes on a des
vues difficiles novices sont des
tragédies et c'était c'était la peur de
mes parents ils avaient peur que j'ai ce
genre de vie
ensuite ils ont vu que c'était pas car
ils ont vu que j'avais des enfants que
je pouvais trouver l'amour c'est tout ce
dont il avait besoin et ils ont très
bien réagi vos paroles un peu à peu vous
commencez à vous sentir homme à
l'extérieur aussi parce que jusque là
vous vous sentiez sommes uniquement à
l'intérieur
votre voix devient plus grave avec les
hormones un votre barbe pousse mais pas
comme on dit chez les franges en pas de
chirurgie dont bas c'est à dire que vous
gardez votre vagin et votre utérus
c'est ça les chirurgies ne sont pas
extraits donc vous pouvez demander à vos
autres invités ce qu'ils pensent de
leurs organes génitaux bon alors on a
remarqué vous leurrez pas posé de
questions sur leurs organes génitaux
mais mais vous me demander à moi mais
bon on imaginer à jamais jamais été une
option pour vous d'abandonner votre
vagin et votre utérus et vous l'acceptez
vos partenaires aussi vous êtes un homme
sans pénis voilà tous vos partenaires
l'ont accepté mais sur votre carte vide
jt c'est ça y'a écrit hommes ja
oui je suis un homme à tous les niveaux
sauf que je n'ai pas cette partie
autonome différents voilà mais vous êtes
un homme en 2010 c'est le coup de foudre
pour beef et quand je vois beef je
comprends alors vous avez une famille
compliquée un beef 20 frères héroïnomane
une soeur qui est également toxico une
soeur qui vit dans une caravane enfin
voilà et un an après votre rencontre à
tous les deux vous recueillez chez vous
ce qui prouve que notre ami tristan a
gardé sa de l'époque de ces de ses
parents un an après votre rencontre vous
recueillez chez vous les enfants de
votre soeur qui est toxicomane il ya une
fille et un garçon haili et riley et là
vous démontrer tous les deux avec ses
deux enfants adoptés votre capacité à
éduquer des enfants ce qui rassure tout
le monde j'imagine ya pour nous c'est
normal finalement de d'accueillir des
enfants dans nos familles les gays les
couverts sont toujours rejetés par leurs
parents et grandissant parents très
souvent
donc nous on connaît bien cette idée
donc on voulait fonder une famille
quelle que soit la manière de le faire
voilà vous éduquez donc les deux enfants
de votre soeur et en 2013 vous décidez
de vous marier et la tristan vous
commencer à rêver d'avoir des enfants
avouent
et en fait j'ai toujours votre utérus
donc en fait c'est possible le médecin
vous dis qu'il faut arrêter les hormones
il faut arrêter la testostérone alors
vous beef quand tristan vous dit qu'il
veut faire un enfant vous êtes assez
réticent parce que vous vous occuper à
plein temps de votre neveu et de votre
nièce riley et elle n'y est finalement
vous dites au moment où il commence à
grandir
au moment où je pourrais être un peu
indépendant je me trouvais avec un gosse
sur les bras c'est le cas d'ailleurs
mais vous l'acceptez finalement parce
que vous l'aimez
oui c'est sûr c'était par amour
j'ai décidé que je devais faire
confiance tristan quand on s'est marié
il m'a pro il m'a promis qu'on aurait
une vie aventureuse
je lui ai laissé guider sept villages
alors tristan vous avez arrêté donc la
testostérone vérité les hormones
ce qui fait de vous au vu les à nouveau
et vous concevez sept enfants avec beef
alors vous le faite à l'ancienne vous le
faites comme les hétéros tristan votre
première grossesse se terminant en
fausse couche
ça se passe mal vous perdez votre bébé
vous ne perdez pas espoir en revanche
mais en 2016
tristan vous êtes en ce1 de l'homme de
votre vie voilà l'histoire alors votre
ventre pouces et je veux dire c'est
qu'il ya c'est extraordinaire d'avoir
quelqu'un avec une barbe dont le ventre
pouces vous prenez des saints évidemment
c'est normal mais vous gardez votre
barbe et votre allure c'est à dire en
fait s'il paraît que c'est irréversible
c'est là vous avez fait l'eurovision bas
alors vous êtes ému la première fois que
vous sentez le bébé bouger dans notre
ventre mais c'est pas pour ça que vous
vous sentez femme en fait
non je n'ai jamais été une femme
enceinte je ne sais pas ce qu une femme
enceinte ressent mais pour moi
personnellement que j'avais l'impression
d'être un homme enceint qu'ils
attendaient un bébé
et voilà ce qui est gentil
alors leo leo qui quand même casse
couilles
mais quand même alors léo est né le 14
juillet merci pour la france est né le
14 juillet 2017 il peser 4 kg 250 et il
mesurait 54 cm 8 à 6 l'accouchement a
été difficile
avec gas oui oui
il ya le même homme et travail le
travail bien sûr en connaissant ça
s'appelle le travail passé c'est du
travail va bien sûr alors vous avez un
père extraordinaire un qui est très
ouvert qui étaient très intelligents qui
et voilà et il a vraiment insisté votre
accouchement votre père
pendant tout le travail pendant tout
l'accouchement la mère de dif aussi mon
père a coupé le cordon quand léo n'est
pas ça qui fait le gros dos je suis né
non c'est pas tous les jours qu'on voit
trop pris sa douche et c'est vrai
[Applaudissements]
alors évidemment et c'est un bernard
pivot qui me dira le contraire parce que
détestent le déferlement de haine sur
les réseaux sociaux il a bien raison là
vous y avait eu droit vous avez des
messages sur les réseaux sociaux qui se
disent on aurait préféré que l'enfant
soit mort né
un enfant en or s'en serait mieux sorti
qu'à un enfant qui serait né de parents
comme nous tous les deux vous n'avez
jamais regretté une seconde que vous
avez fait
c'est là qu'ils sont pas comme des
parents normaux
c'est vrai
est ce que vous avez envie de faire un
deuxième enfant a oui ça c'est la
question non déjà c'est finalement
derrière mais
on est toujours ouvert
pour développer notre aime sa famille et
prendre nos responsabilités dans la vie
mais je n'ai pas pas qu'on aura un autre
enfant biologique ouais et on pleure un
peu parce qu'il aurait préféré être une
fille 1
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
1h10 tube abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu